je fais ce choix à un moment où ma
flamme et m'a combativité sont toujours
bien présentes mais où elles sont
accompagnées d'un besoin devenu
irrépressible de trouver un espace de
liberté et un espace de normalité aussi
en quelque sorte j'ai besoin d'exister
en dehors de la politique
mais enfin la preuve aujourd'hui avec
l'annonce qui a été faite on a appris ça
ce matin il faut quand même rappeler que
le marquer le monde politique au Québec
on dit souvent faire de la politique
autrement elle en était un exemple
probant elle a porté vous le savez les
dossiers tellement importants comme la
médicale à mourir on disait que c'est la
marraine mais elle a travaillé quand
même avec les députés des autres parties
le développer cette idée de l'approche
transpartisale pas lu des complices à
faire ça alors on la présente on l'a
pressenti comme chef du PQ maintenant ça
a passé son tour je pourrais parler de
longuement des faits d'armes de cette
ancienne députée elle a choisi de se
retirer juste avant les dernières
élections elle commence après quoi un an
et quelques mois un nouveau chapitre de
sa vie professionnelle bonsoir Véronique
Yvon bienvenue à 24 60 cette combativité
vous allez la mettre au service dans le
fond de l'université et des étudiants
qui la fréquentent vous allez pour vous
joignez à l'Université de Montréal tout
à fait département de sciences
politiques exactement donc c'est avec
beaucoup de c'est à dire que j'ai
accepté cette main tendue j'ai bien
réfléchi je voulais devant une page
blanche pour me donner toutes les
possibilités justement d'avoir du temps
pour me poser absorber tout ce que j'ai
vécu pendant 14 ans politique donc leur
mémoire
donc c'était pour le dernier chapitre et
puis je vois ça vraiment comme une
opportunité extraordinaire un de
partager ma passion puis de ce que j'ai
vécu et de la pratique de la politique
très concrètement puis de continuer à
travailler pour changer un peu les
choses encore j'espère
des politiques parce que dans le fond
vous allez faire le contre-champ de la
vie politique vous allez enseigner à la
maîtrise d'abord ça donne des gens qui
sont mordu politique comme dirait mon
ami Sébastien alors vous allez
approfondir ces questions là il reste
que vous quittez vous avez quitté la
politique depuis un peu plus d'un an
mais j'imagine que vous avez pas quitté
votre famille politique c'est une
famille pour vous que le parti en fait
j'ai annoncé un peu plus d'un an j'ai
été député jusqu'en octobre
entreprises
quand on l'annonce je reste toujours
très intéressé par la chose politique
c'est certain mais ce qui est formidable
quand on prend un peu de recul c'est
qu'on n'est pas toujours dans le action
réaction de se lever le matin à dire ok
le qu'est-ce qui va être urgence la
journée sur quoi on va me questionner à
chaque jour il faut que j'ai déjà une
idée de faire sur trois nouveaux sujets
donc c'est ça
les journalistes mais c'est normal c'est
la démocratie mais ça va vite vous en
êtes tout à fait conscience dans votre
univers aussi donc c'était ça un peu
j'ai savouré chaque moment de cette
vitre épidante mais là j'ai le goût
d'avoir du temps pour approfondir des
enjeux partager ce que j'ai vécu
travailler avec des étudiants
travaillent avec des professeurs des
chercheurs stimulants mais tout ça
ensemble pour créer avec la maison des
des affaires incubateur un incubateur
développer vraiment pour développer des
projets pilotes en quelque sorte de la
politique publique pour faire en sorte
qu'en fin la recherche et la pratique se
rend compte vraiment mais un des
problèmes que vous avez dû vivre c'est
que les mandats des politiciens des
politiciens c'est 4 ans puis on a
l'impression qu'on développe toujours de
politique pour les réaliser dans son
mandat on sait pas si on paye le prix de
renoncer à ses promesses et un
gouvernement aujourd'hui qui a un score
parfait dans les sondages malgré qu'il
est renié ses promesses électorales donc
comment on vous allez jongler avec cette
pratique politique là qui est de faire
des promesses les Reniers tout en
voulant quand même adopter des
politiques sociales j'ai encore beaucoup
d'idées
grâce ou malgré ces selon mon passage en
politique et je pense qu'on est mûr pour
vraiment revoir comment on fait la
politique puis oui je pense que les gens
en soif d'une politique qui est ancrée
dans le moyen puis dans le long terme on
voit avec le logement on voit avec le
climat on le voit avec l'immigration je
veux dire c'est pas des enjeux qui
peuvent se décider sur un moi en
politique ça m'a frappé ça a été un de
mes premiers chocs quand je suis arrivée
moi je venais de la fonction publique
j'avais travaillé aussi un peu dans le
milieu universitaire à quel point il y
avait des choses qui se décidaient
rapidement sans consomme vers les
données probantes sans construction
toujours vers la recherche ça veut pas
dire de chercher de midi à 14h tout le
temps puis tu peux décider ça veut juste
dire d'être alimenté correctement parce
qu'il peut exister de bons et de beaux
ici ou ailleurs et de se tourner vers la
recherche souvent les chercheurs
trouvent pas leur donner leurs
recherches trouvent pas leur chemin
jusqu'au décideur je trouve que trop
souvent les décideurs se tournent pas
convenablement dans la recherche axée ça
cette idée de cette maison des affaires
publiques internationales autant avec
les décideurs qu'avec les les groupes
communautaires ou les amis de cheveux à
droite parce que ça passe sur le micro
bon on pensait que c'était mon crayon
mais c'est
très très bien vous évoquez votre
parcours et se laisse sous les yeux
parce que les gens vous connaissent
peut-être celle qui a été députés mais
vous avocate j'ai travaillé comme avocat
diplôme mais vous avez une maîtrise en
analyse et planification de politique
sociale de la London School l'école
c'est une institution très prestigieuse
et j'imagine que cette formation là va
continuer de vous inspirer pour vos
propres recherches ou mettre à l'ordre
du jour vos idées pour en faire des
politiques sociales éventuellement en
fait moi ma passion c'était
l'élaboration de politique publique dans
la sphère sociale pour mener à des
réformes sociales pour ceux que j'étais
allé étudier à Londres c'était je
trouvais le programme fait sur mesure
pour ce qui m'intéressait après mon
droit et c'est un peu ça qui m'a habité
pendant ma vie politique donc d'essayer
de faire ces réformes-là en
co-construction un peu avec la société
et d'amener des changements qui vont
être
durablesment prenons l'exemple de la
Cour suprême le norable Wagner ok
comment le droit peut changer la société
puis notamment la médicale à mourir
c'est quand même une décision importante
mais le Québec avait eu cette approche
là donc c'est important l'aide médicale
mourir va toujours rester pour voir un
exemple de progrès de comment on fait
avancer les choses tout en étant à
l'écoute de sa population c'est quoi le
lait exactement en fait je pense que les
ingrédients avec le recul qui ont fait
je pense que ça a fonctionné c'est que
ça répondait clairement à un besoin on a
impliqué la population parce que c'est
quelque chose qui touchait absolument
tout le monde il y en a des fois qui
vont être élus qui vont dire moi j'étais
lu pour décider ce que je décide pas
besoin de consulter comme si c'était une
faiblesse de consulter moi je pense au
contraire quand on consulte et qu'on
construit ensemble quand les choses
atterrissent ben déjà la moitié du
travail est fait parce que le consensus
s'est bâti puis les choses atterrissent
beaucoup plus en douceur et puis je
pense que de se donner du temps même si
en politique on court toujours contre le
temps les échéances électorales marquer
des points je pense que c'est gagnant
que les citoyens nous en sont
reconnaissants après quand les choses
fonctionnent et que ça fait une
différence dans leur vie on a plusieurs
exemples ces derniers mois parce que
c'est ce qu'on est en gestion de crise
oublions l'un instant dans plusieurs
domaines on pense à l'immigration bien
entendu le logement tout à l'heure la
crise du logement qui dure des années
qu'on parle de crise de logement mais
aussi très aigu comment il se fait-il
que ça marche pour que les bureaux
classiques ça bloque l'immigration
Ottawa comme à Québec il y a pas de
service au numéro qu'on compose c'est
incroyable puis
moi je pense que il y a trop de repas
trop mais disons que la grande majorité
des ressources sont mises dans la
fonction publique au bout du processus
donner le service puis déjà là on voit
des failles importantes à être tout de
suite en réponse mais il y a pas eau
assez de ressources dans l'équilibre des
choses sur la planification sur c'est
quoi le bon geste à poser c'est quoi la
bonne politique qu'est-ce qui va faire
la différence oui on le voit avec plein
de dossiers donc je pense que puis pour
avoir travaillé dans la fonction
publique je le vois souvent quand il y a
des coupes quand on a des
réorganisations qu'est-ce qui tombe en
premier c'est les boîtes qui
réfléchissent les boîtes qui font le
lien justement avec les penseurs avec
les chercheurs mais bon sang c'est comme
la prévention en santé si on investit
pas en prévention si on investit pas en
recherche dans nos politiques publiques
mais on se retrouve avec des solutions
inadéquates ou des services qui tiennent
pas la route une petite 30 secondes sur
la le rôle du Parlement des députés
madame Foster
passer à l'enseignement réfléchir sur le
rôle du député parce que c'est important
on a une opposition qu'on dit faible
bien qu'aujourd'hui on va prendre que le
PQ se situe bien c'est une bonne journée
pour vous quand vous regardez je pense
que c'est une bonne journée pour la
démocratie pourquoi parce qu'on peut
rien tenir pour acquis c'est vraiment je
trouve un message un contre message
aussi Nice de voir des fois on pense que
tout est figé dans le béton il y a un an
tout le monde disait que c'était mort le
Parti québécois puis là on voit sur
renaître à cause d'authenticité de
combativité pour vous donc
toujours très passionné par les sujets
mais très bien dans ma vie alors les
auditeurs de la radio à Montréal tout
tomate avec Patrick
vont vous entendre tous les vendredis
matin avec un partenaire dont on connaît
pas l'identité mais vous vous le savez
vous allez garder le secret
alors bienvenue Radio-Canada en tout cas
la radio
merci Véronique qui vont à bientôt au
revoir pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI